A bead artist drills a tiny hole
from the top corner of a
cube bead to the opposite bottom
corner of that bead.
It's a cube bead.
Each edge of the bead
is 1/2 centimeters.
How long is the hole
that she drilled?
So if I'm interpreting this
properly, let me draw that
cube bead, which I will
just draw as a
cube, a big cube here.
Nicer cubes have been drawn in
the history of cube drawing,
but I'll try my best.
So let's see.
This is my best shot
at a freehand cube.
I think that does the
job reasonably well.
If this cube was transparent,
you could even imagine kind of
that backside over there, and
the base of the cube if this
was a transparent cube.
They tell us that each edge of
this cube bead-- they call
this a cube bead-- each edge
of the cube bead is 1/2
centimeter.
So this is 1/2 centimeters, this
is 1/2 centimeters, and
that is 1/2 centimeters.
And then they say that they
drilled a hole from the top
corner of a cube bead to
the opposite bottom
corner of the bead.
From the top corner to
the opposite bottom.
So I think they're talking about
the longest diagonal
that can fit in the cube.
Going from the back, right top
corner, over here, to the
front, left bottom corner, right
over there, that's the
longest diagonal
that could fit.
So let me draw that.
So it would look something
like this.
This is the distance
in question.
How long is the hole
that she drilled?
That is the distance that
we have to figure out.
And let's see how we can
think about that.
And this is a bit of a
classic in terms of
figuring out a distance.
The longest diagonal of
a cube or some type of
a rectangular prism.
And the trick here is to see
that this is the hypotenuse of
a triangle, although the
triangle isn't completely
obvious to you just yet.
And to think about this as
the hypotenuse of a right
triangle, what you have to do
is visualize the diagonal of
the bottom face of this cube.
Think about this diagonal right
here that I'm drawing.
So the diagonal of the bottom
face of this cube.
If you think of it that way,
then all of a sudden we have a
right triangle that's kind of
going across this cube.
This is a right angle
over here.
We know what this length is.
This is 1/2 centimeters.
If we could figure out the
length of this orange side
right here, this part that's
going diagonally across the
base of the cube, then we could
use the Pythagorean
theorem to figure out what the
distance in question is, this
longest diagonal of the cube.
Now, to figure out this orange
side, you just have to
visualize the base
of this cube.
Let's look at this base.
If we were just in the cube
looking straight down at the
base, it would look something
like this.
You'd have this side-- let me
color code them; it will make
it easier to visualize I think--
you have this side
right here, which I will
do in this blue color.
So I'll draw it over here.
You have this side in
that blue color.
And then you have this side over
here, which I'll do in
the magenta color.
You have the side over there
in the magenta color.
They're both of length 1/2, so
I'll draw them with roughly
the same length.
And then you have this orange
side that goes across to the
bottom of the base
of the cube.
And I'll do it as the same
orange dotted line right
there, just like that.
Let me extend this side
a little bit.
And we know this is
a right angle.
This is a cube we're
dealing with, so
this is a right angle.
We know that this side
is 1/2 centimeter.
We know that this side right
over here is 1/2 centimeter.
So if we wanted to figure out
this diagonal or this length
right here, we can just use
the Pythagorean theorem.
We know that 1/2 squared-- if we
called this, I don't know,
if we called this right here
x-- we know that x squared,
the hypotenuse squared, is equal
to the the sum of the
squares of these two guys,
is equal to 1/2
squared plus 1/2 squared.
Or if we want to solve for x, we
could say x is equal to the
square root-- what's
this going to be?
The square root of 1/4, That's
1/2 squared, plus 1/2 squared,
which is 1/4.
Or, what's 1/4 plus 1/4?
So x is equal to the square root
of 1/4 plus 1/4, that's
2/4, or 1/2.
Or you could write that as 1
over the square root of 2.
Now, we could rationalize this,
but I'll leave it like
that for now.
It'll keep things simple.
So this distance right here is
1 over the square root of 2,
or we could say this distance
right over here is 1 over the
square root of 2.
So if we were to draw the
right triangle where the
hypotenuse is the length of that
hole, let me draw that
right triangle.
So we have our hypotenuse,
which is this
long thing over here.
Let me just draw it like this.
That long thing over there.
We have this side over
here in yellow.
This side right here.
We have that side right there.
It is of length 1/2
centimeters.
And then we have the side we
just figured out, this side
right here, that x side.
This right over here.
This side over here, it
is a right angle.
We just figured out
this length.
It is 1 over the square
root of 2 centimeters.
Now, to figure out the length of
the hole, we can apply the
Pythagorean theorem again.
This is, let me say
h for hole.
Length of hole.
Actually, even better,
let's say l.
l for length.
Then we can say that l squared
is going to be equal to 1 over
the square root of 2 squared--
we're just applying the
Pythagorean theorem--
plus 1 squared.
And once again, we know that
this is the longest side.
It's opposite the right angle.
So it's going to be the
sum of the squares of
the other two sides.
And so that's going to be equal
to-- so we get l squared
is equal to-- what's 1 over the
square root of 2 squared?
Well, 1 squared is 1, over the
square root of 2 squared is 2.
And then you're going to
have plus 1/2 squared.
1/2 squared is plus 1/4.
So l squared is equal
to 1/2 plus 1/4.
1/2 plus 1/4 is what?
Let's do it over here.
1/2-- we can write it as 2/4--
plus 1/4 is equal to 3/4.
So this right here
is equal to 3/4.
So we have l squared-- I changed
the shades of green
just there-- is equal to 3 over
4, so l is equal to the
square root of 3 over 4.
So we take the square root of
both sides, you get l is equal
to the square root of 3 over
the square root of 4.
What's the square root of 4?
The square root of 4 is 2.
And we're done.
The length of the hole that was
drilled in this bead from
this corner over here all the
way over here is the square
root of 3 over 2 centimeters.
Because everything we've been
dealing with has been
centimeters.